what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have huge thor
love and thunder teaser trailer news
today after waiting so long for this
trailer after it breaking the record for
the least amount of days between the
official release of the teaser trailer
and the movie in theaters we finally
have some official news it looks like
the trailer is officially done and this
is coming from somebody directly at
marvel studios somebody working on the
film he is part of the cast so very very
official this is coming from gorov
chopra and i hope i pronounced that
right if i didn't i apologize but he is
the hindi voice dub actor for chris
hemsworth and he might have done a
marvel no no today he posted to his
instagram a picture of him in the studio
doing the voiced up work for the thor
love and thunder official teaser he
posted to his story today and it says
thor love and thunder trailer done can't
wait for you guys to see it then he put
hashtag thor hashtag indian thor and he
added marvel and disney india now maybe
marvel gave him permission to do this
maybe he did it on his own either way
not too much harm done here it's not
like he's given out any major spoilers
for the movie or anything but he's a
champion to us because this confirms
that the thor love and thunder trailer
is officially done they have all of the
footage that they need and it's edited
the way that they want it because they
are sending this out to the voice actors
now so pretty much everything has to be
done and in place now of course they
could always change things or edit some
things but for the most part the trailer
is done now the big question is of
course when is it going to be coming out
well marvel studios has a tendency to
release trailers early on monday morning
about 9am eastern time typically and
today's monday morning and it didn't
come so i'm not saying that it's not
going to be coming this week however i
would guess that it would probably come
next week but keep in mind this is just
me guessing based on what they've done
in the past before we haven't heard
anything about an exact release date but
here's some other good news some of you
might have seen yesterday that there are
new thor loving thunder marvel legends
series action figures coming out and
they were pretty revealing i'll do a
full breakdown later but the biggest
thing to take away from this is that
promotion for the movie has begun
they're doing the press tour right now
chris hemsworth confirmed this and they
have all of these promotional products
and toys ready to go which is always a
good sign that the trailer is going to
come out because you can't really
promote stuff too much without the
trailer finally telling people what
exactly the movie is about and today we
have confirmation that the trailer is
officially done and it is being dubbed
in other languages now so we should get
it really really soon keep an eye out
for it this week if not keep an eye out
for it next week for sure since it's
done hopefully they don't tease us much
longer and they actually do drop the
trailer pretty soon but let me know how
excited you are for the thor love and
thunder trailer to finally come out in
the comments down below don't forget to
give the video a like and don't forget
to subscribe so you can stay up on all
the latest thor love and thunder news
and of course mcu news as well for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
[Music]